[Music]
have you ever wished you could strap a
bunch of balloons to your house and then
just
fly away well in the movie up from pixar
that's exactly what happens
except it's an animated movie so it can
ignore the laws of physics
but what if it didn't how many balloons
would you really need
to lift the house from up
[Music]
the filmmakers at pixar are absolute
masters of storytelling they will do
anything to make sure that their stories
are incredible
even if that means sacrificing the laws
of physics to achieve them but i mean
that's understandable
realism hasn't exactly been a priority
for pixar what with all of the
toys cars and fish that can talk
so play nice pete doctor directed not
only
up but monsters inc inside out and more
recently
soul what can i say the guy knows how to
make a great movie
first thing they did when we pitched
this film was like to calculate how many
balloons would it actually take it's
26.5 million
fyi we have about 10 000 so we cheated
there's a great analysis on the film
theory channel that estimates the house
would require
31 million party balloons just to float
that is a lot of balloons in fact the
closest we ever came to that number in
real life was back in 1986
when one and a half million balloons
were released upon cleveland ohio
as cool as it looks it was a bit of a
disaster no one's ever attempted this
sort of thing again but that's still
only five percent of the balloons that
would be needed to lift the house
if only there was a way to show you a
hundred percent
[Music]
31 million balloons at this scale you
don't even really see individual
balloons anymore
instead we're treated to a view of the
wind currents the balloons ride because
this is how you see wind all you need is
just a really beefy computer
however there's a problem using that
many party balloons simply isn't
feasible if we wanted to actually do
this for real we'd want to take a page
out of david blaine's book
and use weather balloons
but why do balloons go up
it all started a couple thousand years
ago with this dude named archimedes who
figured out how
buoyancy what do you say are archimedes
archmeds yeah archimedes ah yurika
you're right
basically this dude archimedes figured
out how buoyancy works
any submersed object that is lighter
than the fluid it pushes aside will
float to the top
this is most commonly understood with
water but it applies to air as well
because air
is a fluid the idea behind archimedes
principle is that
whenever you displace a fluid it
actually pushes back up
by the same amount as the weight of that
displaced fluid
pretty cool huh so even though air is
pretty lightweight
a big enough volume of air can actually
be pretty heavy if you could displace
that with something lighter
you produce an upwards lifting force and
that is called buoyancy
so what is lighter than air
well the first thing you're probably all
familiar with would be helium
it has a density of 0.18 kilograms per
cubic meter
making it seven times lighter than air
but helium still has weight too which is
going to counteract how much it can lift
hydrogen on the other hand is better it
weighs less
so it can lift more it's also like
significantly easier and cheaper to
produce than helium so like
why don't we put hydrogen in our
balloons show the world's largest
airship heading for lakehurst new jersey
filled with hydrogen a highly
inflammable gas
the airship was hailed by thousands who
little dreamed it was their final
glimpse of the hindenburg
oh yeah right it's because hydrogen is
incredibly dangerous
which is unfortunate because we're kind
of running out of helium it's produced
as a byproduct of uranium decay over the
course of millions of years
combining with pockets of natural gas
underground
that's right to get helium we drill for
it
don't worry though for now we still have
plenty of helium left but what if in the
future there is a way to harness
something even better
nothing a vacuum is the lightest
possible substance because it literally
weighs nothing it is the absence of
everything it's what outer space is made
out of
the problem is that a balloon only works
by pressurizing the inside with a gas
which inflates the balloon the structure
comes from that inside
pressure a vacuum on the other hand does
the opposite so normal balloons wouldn't
work
it requires a strong and rigid structure
and is therefore usually made out of
like glass or metal so it's pretty heavy
definitely too heavy to fly like a
balloon so imagine a futuristic material
that weighs next to nothing but is also
incredibly strong
some sort of maybe graphene or carbon
nanotube type deal i don't know it's the
future it's all kind of magic anyway
if you could make a giant vacuum balloon
you'd have the most effective lighter
than air vehicle possible
lifting the house from up would need a
balloon 75 meters wide
and to be clear this is the upper limit
of theoretical balloon technology
what's cool about this idea though is
that if the material could be flexible
or stiff on command you'd end up with
something you could even deploy in the
field
think of the fulton recovery system from
metal gear solid 5.
in the game you can extract people by
attaching a balloon that inflates and
then flies away
i think the idea is that they inflate
with helium but the game already doesn't
make sense so vacuum balloons would have
totally worked and also would have been
way cooler so even though this is
fantasy lifting people with balloons is
actually super doable for instance
here's the amazing balloon stunt
performed by david blaine ascension is
the most
ambitious performance of my life between
the weight of his body and the framework
and the electronics the balloons had to
lift about
400 pounds although if he had access to
a futuristic vacuum balloon
it would only have to be 20 feet wide
way more tactical
but of course that wasn't his goal he
was specifically going for the amazing
image of a person flying through the sky
by just holding on to some balloons
it really is just an absolutely
incredible visual and i think that's
what makes the house from up so
compelling because we can imagine a
group of balloons just carrying us away
so realistically speaking what would the
house up
look like like oh it looked like
interestingly this has kind of already
been done before
jonathan trapp managed to get a real
house up over 10
000 feet suspended from just balloons
that's
really impressive however the house was
gutted to be as lightweight as possible
so
does it even still count as a house see
here's the thing
the old queen and style house from up is
mega heavy
film theory calculated that it weighs
000 pounds that is several times heavier
than an average house
now i'm no expert in estimating the
weight of houses but this makes it
heavier than the statue of liberty
that is a chungu's house my friends and
that might seem completely nuts until
you realize that the hindenburg weighed
480 thousand pounds
and it flew across the atlantic ocean
before it exploded
[Music]
of course so to lift the house from up
we need some very robust balloons
specifically latex weather balloons
meant for carrying experiments high into
the atmosphere
thanks to the help of diana the physics
girl we know that a 2 meter wide balloon
can lift about eight pounds in addition
to the weight of the balloon itself
we are of course oversimplifying a lot
of factors here including how
balloon lift actually changes depending
on the temperature
they lift more on a colder day and after
crunching all of the numbers
we end up with 80 000 weather balloons
and
this is what that looks like
[Music]
this just might be the closest you'll
ever get to seeing the house from up
flying with realistic physics to
legitimately do it for real would simply
be prohibitively expensive
keep in mind that each balloon could
also fit a person inside of it
also in addition to lifting the house
the balloons have to lift themselves too
in fact the weight of just the balloons
accounts for a third of the total flying
weight
it's a pretty incredible sight seeing
all these balloons lifting a house but
it's easy to see why pixar decided not
to go this realistic route here
having this many balloons and worrying
so much about the physics really would
have gotten in the way of this story
because a movie is just that a story it
doesn't owe reality anything
it sets its own rules and in the rules
of pixar
a few thousand party balloons are all
you need to fly away from your problems
thank you so much for watching everyone
this was a really fun video to throw
together there's no sponsor on today's
episode however
we've got a website quarterdigital.com
go check it out and subscribe to that
because that is probably the best way
to support more of these videos on top
of that we've got a whole bunch of shows
exclusively on the website they're all
pretty cool we brought the vlogs back we
even have son of a dungeon our
own d d campaign using some really cool
real-time tech
of the whole game board it's awesome
also we have our own version of a master
class
if you want to get into filmmaking or
visual effects it's called functional
filmmaking i even made an episode about
how i make these types of science videos
check it out on the website all those
shows are coming soon i'm hoping to make
a lot more of these videos this year i
want to be on the moon i want to see how
many solar panels power the world
with your support maybe i'll get to make
them this year thanks for watching and
share the video